we stand here
at a hospital that has been at the very
heart
of the care of the nhs
from hospitals in glasgow
to communities in yorkminster
[Music]
train stations in london
and hospices in solihull
from the houses of parliament to
political chambers up and down the
country
standing in silence to remember and
reflect
her majesty send him flowers and thanks
to staff at saint bart's hospital
who cared for prince philip during his
recent illness
a nation and its prime minister paul's
in to remember those we have lost
in a year that has touched us all in
different ways
it's been very difficult i can't do that
it's been the monotony
of the days with not being able to go
go where you wanted to go and do things
a lot of people were lost but at the
same time i feel like something that
society has gained is like a sense of
like togetherness
i do think people are reflect will be
reflecting today um and probably
reflecting on
where they were when the announcement
was made a year ago
the pm spent much of his year here doing
this
a year since he announced the first
national lockdown
and we're in one still when i asked you
to go into
lockdown exactly a year ago it seemed
incredible
that in the 21st century this was the
only way to fight a new
respiratory disease for month after
month
our collective fight against coronavirus
was like fighting
in the dark against a callous and
invisible enemy until science
helped us to turn the lights on and to
gain the upper hand
step by step jab by jab this country
is on the path to reclaiming our
freedoms
what do you think the main social health
and economic challenges will be
and will we be grappling with the legacy
of covid in the past year
for the rest of our lives beth i
certainly think that this is something
that we will all remember and
be dealing with in different ways for
probably for certainly in my case for as
long as uh
as i live it's been an extraordinary uh
moment in our in our in our history and
a deeply
difficult and distressing period not
least for him personally having nearly
lost his own life to the virus
now looking towards trying to fix the
future
but the legacy issue i think for me is
education
and it's the loss of of learning
for so many uh children and young people
that's the thing we've got to focus on
covet itself i anticipate being with us
for the foreseeable future we'll have to
deal with it in some form or another now
science has
extraordinarily responded to this we
will be able to bring it down to
manageable
levels but it's not going away so we
will have covid
for the indefinite future living with
the consequences of clovid for years to
come
the labour leader demanding we learn the
lessons too
i think the government was very slow to
react
and we owe both the nhs staff and those
on the front line
and all the families of those that have
died
to learn the lessons of the last 12
months to have an inquiry and to learn
what went wrong to make sure that we
never repeat that
when boris johnson stood inside number
10 on this very day a year ago
and told us all to stay at home neither
he
nor we really understood what was about
to hit
this country and as the end of this
crisis
finally comes into view there will be
a day of reckoning to both remember
those who lost their lives
but also to learn the lessons of what
went wrong
so we can get it right when the next
pandemic hits
but tonight we remember a doorstep
vigil in westminster
and in south wales this community coming
together to pay
its respects
[Music]
the buildings of bradford illuminated
and blackpool towers shining brightly in
memory of those lives lost
to the capital a city and a country
changed forever
the long road back begins beth rigby
sky news westminster